I was also on Sexton city as a headless
stripper I don't think I was
you never saw my face but I was that was
my first on-camera job was I was a
headless stripper it was not great it
was the episode where Charlotte admits
to Anthony that she's sleeping with
Harry her divorce lawyer and they're in
a bar so the scene starts and it's two
men in speedos like grinding against
each other and that's me and another
young man and then it comes down to
kristin davis and mario Cantona they're
just like watching us talking about that
and I had never been on a film set like
that before and I was like the other guy
and I had to like oil each other up in
front of everyone it was just like fifty
background like staring at us and then
Kristin Davis it's like sitting there
like watching me like put baby oil on I
was like the hell's happening so for a
long time it was a credit that I left
them right now I feel free that I can
just mention that to be like yes I was a
headless stripper but then cut two girls
on that very same soundstage at silver
cup in in Long Island City and then I
got to actually speak lines for the
first time on television but for HBO and
on that very same stage so it's pretty
crazy